boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki and
we are on site in San Jose at the
convention center at the American
Anthropological Association their Triple
A is having their annual meeting and we
are getting to sit down with some of
their anthropologists that are
professors there in academia they are
researchers they are studying biology or
they are studying archaeology or
linguistics there or cultural
anthropology there's so much to apply to
anthropology it's so fascinating and I'm
like I'm a kid in a knowledge Haven
right now it's so amazing and we are our
first guest as we sit down we have dr.
Elyse Waterston joining us on the show
Elyse was the vice president of the
triple-a in 2013 2015 she was the
president of the triple-a from 2015 to
2017 so that's already like four major
years of triple-a involvement that's a
lot of work it's a big organization
there's like almost 6,000 people here
yes yeah that's a huge organization and
so your cult she's a cultural
anthropologist and professor of
anthropology at John Jay College of
Criminal Justice at the City University
of New York with a focus on how systemic
violence and inequality influence
society she's a six-time author she has
an ethnographic book called my father's
Wars which we'll talk about and we will
also talk about her upcoming book called
light in dark times the human search for
meaning so Wow at least what a cool
background thank you so much Alan you
are so cool this is super fun so how
does one like you tell us about your
story about how you got into
anthropology okay well first of all I
really enjoy the way you described you
know your excitement about anthropology
and all of its different aspects and
it's what's what's so true you really
hit on something
really very true about the discipline
which is you know it's students a it
introduction to anthropology learn it's
a holistic discipline and it sounds you
know almost trite after a while but it
is so true because most other
disciplines take a slice of reality and
take a look at it whether it's economics
or whether it's religion or some other
aspect of life social life or biological
life or whatever and and examine it
which is a good thing but
anthropologists start with the big
picture it's holistic and it says ok
here we have the big picture and how do
we understand all the different parts
and how they're connected with one
another and that's what I love about
anthropology so without giving you a
long-winded description of how I got
into it I will tell you that I started
out in my 20s as an as a school teacher
in Brooklyn and started to do research
in my own community was a very poor
community and my big question I didn't
study anthropology as an undergraduate
but my big question as a person living
in the world and living in a very poor
neighborhood working with children who
were really struggling with it's sort of
structural vulnerabilities I I wanted to
understand more deeply how could in the
wealthiest nation in the world and this
is the 1970s there be so much poverty
and when I went to figure out I didn't
need to study this and I couldn't go on
there was no internet to go Google
disciplines
I had majored in psychology as an
undergraduate so I went to the library
and I studied different of the social
sciences to see and I landed on
anthropology and once I landed on
anthropology and read up on it I knew it
would never ever go away would and its
message your interest wouldn't end it
would not end it's really endless
so cool you're speaking about it from
such a multidisciplinary perspective
which is what our show is all about and
so it's very awesome that anthropology
is a huge the study of humans is such a
huge multidisciplinary field so when you
when you see the inequalities and when
you see you ask yourself what is how
what is the root of this how can we get
to the roots not the not that not not
solving them from a a aesthetic
perspective but solving them from roots
systemic perspective well the thing is
and anthropologists often say and then
people glaze their eyes over when they
hear anthropologists say it's
complicated but it is complicated and so
one of the things that you know I
discovered when I was in graduate school
trying to understand the world was what
those different aspects are are that are
forces that shape what human lives are
and become and so that's why you
mentioned you know biological
anthropology and archeology historical
and language and linguistics and
cultural so so you know if we're gonna
understand something like poverty you
can't have a simple simplistic or simple
one-liner answer to it
but you do have to look at the ways in
which the interplay of power.yes and
politics and economics and the economic
organization of a society and its
political structures and its political
ideology all play into creating the
field within which people live out their
lives and so often we refer to that
field in a society like ours as a
structurally unequal field
and so that doesn't mean to say that
human beings living within that or on
that field are just you know complete
and total victims you know other
structures it means that we have to look
at the ways in which human beings
interact with the systems in place the
institutions of social institutions of
society everything from the family which
is a social institution to you know you
know when you deal with issues around
poverty for example the marketplace the
money
well money your value between people
well yes and that has to do with the
economic organizations of society and
then but although other institutions
like you know the market place is an
institution but you know when you think
about poverty and you see how poverty is
criminalized so you have to look at
things like the criminal justice
institution if you're going to talk
about how you're going to when you think
about poverty when you think about
poverty you think you have to think
about what human beings satisfy their
basic needs food so we know we have food
insecurity shelter we know we have
issues around housing and homelessness
but these are not just separate
segmented aspects it all comes together
to a big picture a bet to a help us
understand how human beings navigate on
this unequal field and to also to
navigate it for sustenance and survival
but also navigated to enjoy life to it
too to have love in their lives and to
have joy in their lives even amidst
hardship and difficulty yes and that's
in human search for meaning is you know
and in the upcoming book that you're
writing about so you know the the way
that you you know you're describing it's
so beautiful humans want to have the
basic necessities they want to have the
the highest emotions and feelings that
one can feel there in their lives as
well so how does how did you go from
being becoming fascinated with
anthropology to becoming a professor
writing books through Jordan being a
leader
of Triple A so these are great questions
and I I have to think through the short
version of a long life history and so
let me try to answer your question that
um so as I said once I discovered
anthropology I knew it was going never
going to go away
I didn't start graduate school until I
was 29 or 30 years old and and I got
through that and then ultimately I but
I've been in New York and so my field my
research my fieldwork was in New York I
have a couple of books out about urban
poverty in the US so wanted book is on
women and homelessness in New York City
and I have another book about the street
drug scene in New York during the 1980s
so these are all issues around poverty
so it is an urban poverty sort of
subfield within the field of cultural
anthropology and I came to John Jay
College in 2003 and it was it was
wonderful to be part of that department
and the Institute and the institution of
higher education there because I was
very much nurtured to fulfill my own
potential in what I wanted to do with my
work one of the reasons I love working
at CUNY and at John Jay is that it's a
public university and I believe in the
public a public education so I'm
thrilled to work in a in that kind of
institution and I think we need to
support our public institutions which
are not getting enough support but our
students are primarily working-class a
working poor students of color and new
immigrants and meant many of most are
first-generation college students and I
love working with our students because
they are there because they want to be
there they are there because they
they want to find their their
aspirational and they really are very
dedicated to really at my school trying
to participate in the world to make it a
better place so you know the university
the college has a tagline educating for
justice and when you walk into the
building of my University of my college
at John Jay there's a big wall of words
next to justice and so it's you know
criminal justice and there's social
justice and there's economic justice
climate justice gender justice racial
justice yeah and poetic justice they
actually have poetic justice on the wall
and it's and it's that it's it's you
know it's true it's it's a place where
we explore the idea of justice from
multiple angles and working with our
students has just been a great honor and
my greatest pleasure well so many
variances of justice that's yeah that
are Wow
we just give us a quick one sentencer on
on justice well to me justice has to do
with fairness I mean and of course we
can interpret justice in many ways as I
just said but so what we do in our
department is really focus on social
justice and even that we can unpack that
those two words but basically it's about
for me it is about understanding the
those multiple obstacles to providing
opportunity for people to fulfill their
own potential and where there is
injustice means that there are forces in
place there are structures in place and
then there are four there there is there
are powerful forces that inhibit the
ability for every individual to fulfill
that potential and we call that
structural violence okay so that's a
good way to put it so then there's this
actualization potential of every human
and then the obstacles that are in the
way that are socially constructed more
social violence that's it's a form of
violence and it's invisible yeah because
you don't see it it's not like if I
punched you in the nose yeah you would
see it but structural violence is more
invisible so it's very difficult to even
talk about it because it's an
abstraction but you can you can take it
apart and and look at all those
different structures and systems and see
the ways they work and at the same time
not reduce human beings to you know
simply the victims of such structures
and systems they are we all are
we are also actors though in the world
too
and we find spaces in between to
actualize as as much as possible it
doesn't mean everybody can fulfill that
potential because if they if they
if the playing field is uneven then your
you know it's difficult to find social
justice but I didn't answer your
question about how I got to triple-a
let's get right to there so you know you
you mentioned earlier that there are six
thousand people here at the conference
and it's very intimidating especially
for a junior scholar when you first come
in and it's like oh my god everybody
knows everybody else and I don't know
anybody and oh my god and who's that and
who's this and people are looking at my
nametag
you know they're looking at my mates see
if I'm anybody important and I'm really
not important and it's very intimidating
and I was very intimidated but it was
for me it was the triple-a that actually
enabled the as the organization that
enabled me to really it helped me
develop a wonderful network of friends
and colleagues in around the world and
to really find my own sense of mice
anthropological self yeah and so I met
people and then I was invited
you always need somebody to bring you in
and I think so I was invited by Maria
Vesperia
to write something for a publication
through the triple-a that she was
involved in and that invitation opened
the door for me and then I submitted the
piece the written piece and she liked it
and then she asked me to serve as an
editor for something and I did that and
then from there it just grew and then I
volunteered in various capacities
through the Association and the more I
did that the more people came to me and
asked me to participate in other things
and this committee and that entity and
the other thing and so eventually it got
to the point where you know I became an
elected member of the exec I was on
various committees related to the
transition to electronic publishing for
example that was earlier and on the long
range planning committee things like
that
thence I was elected to the Executive
Board and then somebody on the Executive
Board watched me and wanted to nominate
me for president and ice I said I don't
think so and then she said yes so and
she did and then then I became president
I was elected so that's how I that was
my trajectory it's one step at a time
yes and it's a lot of work and
dedication but you know I really believe
that the Association which is designed
to advance the discipline of
anthropology which is a marginal
discipline in the world so it's very
important that we have our professional
organization that can help all of us
advance our discipline yes and it really
accomplishes an enormous amount doesn't
necessarily always get credit for what
it does but I in my book it's it's a
it's a really great strong organization
that does help us as anthropologists
produce and disseminate knowledge and
information which is what it's all about
yes about humans and about culture about
behavior mmm-hmm about everything around
us and these abstractions as well are
very important to understand now as you
were speaking we're talking about these
you know the committees and as I was
walking through I was looking at all the
different committed laws some of the
different committees and holy cow
there's so many and yes you're working
on so many different things here and
you're the way that you work through it
totally makes sense now
she started professing you started
professing in 2003 2003 was where I got
the full-time position as a as a
professor 15 years now that's a long
time that's awesome so maybe give us a
quick bit on what have been some of your
favorite learning processes as a
professor and that your engagements of
students your ability to expand their
minds to new ways of thinking okay so I
will give you one example
I'm actually teaching a brand new course
right now that I could share with you as
well but but first I'm gonna start with
a course that I really enjoyed teaching
that's because we're a school of
criminal justice a lot of the a lot of
the courses have names that sound that
are kind of have a criminal justice or
something like that
hook so there's this one course that's
called culture and crime and when I
would teach that course I would ask the
students you know in you know the first
day of class what do you think this
course is going to be about and they
invariably say well it's going to be why
do you know some cultural groups commit
certain crimes and why is it you know so
and and and I knew that that's what they
would say you know they would if it's
almost like demonizing cultural groups
you know before we even started about
you know why does why do they commit
crimes and why do they commit these
kinds of crimes you know so is those
kinds of things that I knew they were
say and I said what I always would say
well actually this course is going to be
very intense but it's about crimes of
power war and genocide culture and crime
whoa and so it's you know a tough course
but you know it we really a lot of
different kinds of interdisciplinary
literature from
anthropological works to poetry to you
know to you know to have students
understand war and political violence
and crimes against humanity in those
kinds of ways and genocide and had them
produce works in multiple formats like
and graphic format or you know different
kinds of narratives and things like that
so we use multiple different approach
writing approaches to have them
articulate what they were learning and
in at my school often there is the
military recruiting students and our
students are vulnerable to being
recruited by the military because you
know they are working-class working poor
students and sometimes they you know in
the literature is the recruitment
literature is very appealing it's you
know will pay for your education will
you know and so forth and so at but I
had students come up to me after this
class and say you know I had the papers
to join the military in my pocket but
after this course there's no way I'm
joining the military and the thing is
that I you know I didn't propagandize I
didn't say y'all you know you shouldn't
join it was never about that but it was
about understanding let's study war yeah
let's study specific Wars let's study
what philosophers have said about war
let's study what anthropologists have
learned by going into war zones those
kinds of things and and then that got
them thinking and then they realized
that this decision to enter the armed
forces really requires careful deep
consideration and not just an ottoman
I'll do it because I'll get an education
for my love pay for my schooling mm-hm
and so that to me is an accomplishment
because we want the students to think
for themselves and think critically we
always say that
oh we're gonna teach students to think
critically but
actually we don't you know because we
don't really give them the tools often
enough for them to think critically so
that's one example I won't go into
details at this course I'm teaching now
but it's a writing course just quickly
on the last thing that you said Wow
there's so many variables that go into
why we have war and when we break them
down at at their roots and we try and
find some sort of peace love and
understanding on planet there is less of
a need for war and hopefully in within
this century we can find some sort of
world peace it's something that we care
about a lot and that we talk about a lot
and it there's a there's a big shift
towards towards heart coherence the sort
of of empathy and emotional intelligence
that people can carry with their with
their stewardship for earth and what
their care for each other that I think
could get us there and I think is
starting to get us there in many ways so
I'd be interested to see how much you
here at triple-a also speak on world one
world peace and well okay so a couple of
comments and response to what you just
said number one is that there can't be a
peace without justice okay so that's one
thing because we can have peace and
people could you know not war and people
can be really immiseration I mean you
know and have lives that are very
difficult because of these conditions
that you know are not peaceful that
invisible violence that I was talking
about earlier so that's one thing I
think the other thing is that we we have
to look at the political economics the
political economy of war historically
and in the present and
no one quickie way to kind of get a
picture of it is looking at the budgets
the military budgets and so we in our
society in the u.s. the military budget
keeps growing 800 billion now and and
you know so we've got to follow the
money follow the money and then follow
the relationships to you know to the the
like other countries the geopolitical
relations well the true but I'm talking
about follow the money and the tools and
technology of war oh yeah these are
produced and reproduced and sold and you
know and and how there's a market for
war you know Sophie and I'm not reducing
war to that but I think it's an
important piece of it that we have to
really understand and billions of
dollars of weapons moving around the
world via right so you have to look at
those kinds of big picture factors and
then you have to look at the ideological
factors the sort of the rhetoric around
war and I was in a panel on Wednesday
called cowardice hmm and unpacking that
concept and you know one of the you know
the part of the discussion then that
panel was that you know there's often I
hear this all the time that people say
Oh human beings will always be at war
because they always were and they always
will it's in our genes it's in our
nature and you laugh but this is people
say it all the time yeah you you know at
Thanksgiving time go ask just bring the
subject up and at your own family table
and you will hear people say that but if
we're saying the word always an
inevitable we'll never have them answer
and it's also the the anthropological
record the bio cultural anthropological
record shows that's not true because
human beings have the potential to be
and as you said actually
you know it's it's a more more adaptive
in many depending on the circumstance to
be caring and to be cooperative and
those kinds of things and so the concept
of coward and the hero is part of the
ideological armature of you know this
condition of militarism that you know
has I mean my students they don't want
to be cowards they want to be heroes but
you have to unpack them the words and
understand this is where linguistic
anthropology comes in as well because we
take a word that we think we know what
it means and we think when you know it's
we take it for granted but if you start
to take it apart you start to see how
powerful the word is because it evokes
such powerful images and has us
responding them to them in a certain way
what is it that we want to be how do I
want to be identified we hear it every
time there is a news you know terrible
news tragedy or somebody does something
wonderful to help other people they say
you're a hero you know and then the
person says I'm not a hero I was just
doing my job or whatever but they this
construct of hero anyway so you get the
idea that that you know it's um this is
all part of what we have to take apart
to understand human kind and and the
meanings people attached to things to
words to our Diaz and to practices yes
yes and if we to make that cultural
shift we have to put these
the linguistical practice is all into
movement in order to make these changes
to geopolitical changes etc let's touch
on my father's Wars ok ok so this is
about your father yes so my father's
Wars is the full title is my father's
Wars migration memory and the violence
of a century so you can see so much of
my work and my interests are around
these issues around displacement
dispossession diaspora war violence and
structural and systemic violence I as
you said and it's he cut its effects on
human lives and so I my father has a
very interesting life history he lived
across the 20th century he was born in
Eastern European Jew in a place called
Vietnam night Poland and his his
migration trajectory was from Poland to
Cuba to the United States to San Juan
Puerto Rico and so he has this really
interesting story that crosses cultures
language groups continents nation-states
and Wars he lived through he lived his
in the course of his life he lived
through two wars and a revolution and so
and my father was a not a very easy
person to get along with for me anyway I
can speak for myself and and but he also
had was a great storytelling always had
storyteller and always had was pretty
open about talking about the past and I
was very fascinated by his stories even
as a child and then later it it
won't go into all the background but it
came to me that I really wanted him to
be the subject of my of a study with him
as the as the base as the heart of it
but edged out from his life story to a
larger social history so often in
scholarly work we might look at a topic
like let's say war and we might even
look at a war or we might look at
migration and look at a pattern of
migration of these folks from there to
here you know like that is circumscribed
and good but what I wanted to do was
look at a life and look at it across all
these terrains so that we could
understand a multiplicity of forces but
also change and transformation so to
give you a hint a kind of a cultural
hint about the changes my father his own
life and bodies and you know is his name
he was born menachem mendel Vassar Steen
and in Cuba in a little town called
Megiddo
he became Miguelito because Mendel is
like translates to me golly I mean
Mendeley is the diminutive in Yiddish he
became Miguelito in Havana he became
Miguel and then later he became Michael
Waterston that's how I got my last name
what a fascist ocean of an evolution of
a name that suggests and then at the end
of his life in Puerto Rico he was known
as Don Miguel so you can imagine and I
and there are photographs of him you
have a photograph of him from Poland as
a little boy he looks like it's from
Poland from 19-teens
hey you know in 1920s then you have him
in Havana he looks like a you know he
had he has the whole aura of this young
man in Havana and then as an American as
a photograph of him as an American
soldier he looks like mmm
can soldier anyways and so forth so it's
really interesting because those
photographs - those are artifacts that
suggest meanings very anthropological
very cultural these are like different
lives they're different lives but it's
one life for this one line and it's a
life that reflects it's it's it's what I
tried to do in telling that my
description of him was to show him you
know in his I wasn't going to put him up
on a pedestal and I wasn't going to put
him down you know and demonize him I
wanted to show him as a real live
flesh-and-blood human being who had his
strengths and his weaknesses and his
faults and his assets and and and he
lived through a violent century and he
managed and adapted and maneuvered
sometimes and and I and it was a
reflection of the human struggle and so
we I called this my colleague Barbara
Wilco Bower and I developed a term for
this approach of working with one's own
parent and we call it intimate
ethnography because I did this study as
a daughter
but as an anthropologist as well yeah so
it's an anthropologist daughter or
daughter anthropologist study of her own
father which is not something that's
usually done in our field which we need
to do more of because there's not enough
intimate ethnology intimate ethnography
enough ethnography yeah ethnography this
the study of culture well ethnography is
an approach to research but it's also
the final product your book okay okay
and then ethnography customs of
individuals and cultures yeah you don't
say it like that okay and so we I think
we need more intimate ethnography
because it
will enable us to better document the
evolution of different cultures and it's
not just the evolution of cultures
because but it's because that by using
that word suggests that there is a
trajectory but it isn't so much a
trajectory as it is at particular
moments in time and in place you have
people who or have organised themselves
and understand their lives and are in
social relationship with one another and
are in social relationship with the
power structures that they find
themselves in and it's in it's a dynamic
it's either it's a process and a dynamic
so it's not so much an evolution which
is too linear to you know often we
conceptualize evolution to lynnie in the
documentation of the variables that the
person evolved within that timeline had
the existence what their life was like
cuz all of the different variables that
your father went through the wars and
the Revolution and changing it from a
you know from a soldier to of and the
migrations yeah the my arrangement and
this not movements and well social
policy because his family tried to get
to the u.s. in 1924 but the u.s.
immigration law changed at that time to
prevent people like my father from
coming in just like it's so relevant to
some of the things happening now because
they didn't want the riffraff in mm-hmm
they didn't want people from Eastern
Europe and southern Europe to come into
the United States that were going to
pollute the American
Varick German yeah there's there's this
also this strange way that I started
perceiving now um intimate ethnography
where I started thinking about well why
not
who do you choose the document who do
you not choose to document because
somebody that lives in a in a rural town
for 80 years and they live and die in
that rural town maybe in the middle of
the US or in the middle of anywhere else
on the planet just what why would it be
important to document that you know that
type of so I think everybody has a life
history now anthropologists don't
necessarily look at one individual like
I did in this particular case I mean my
study of women and homelessness I looked
at many in too many people but but you
know and you know anthropologist immerse
themselves in a particular place and get
to know people in that place and it's
it's not necessarily the kind of thing
that I did here although in our
discipline we do have tradition of doing
life history research you know of
individual life histories cool
you know everybody has history
everybody's family has a history and I
know that my intimate ethnography which
is a life story that's a social history
because we are all social beings so
there's always going to be a social
history that that that's behind that
surrounds that person that you just
described that imaginary person in the
rural area you know where do they come
from like they are not an island unto
themselves there's there is something
there is a story there but you're
they're more reason to document a Nobel
laureate or someone that led a genocide
is there more reason to document that
well that's interesting question because
one of the things about my book I think
is that is a contribution is that it's
an ordinary person and you know who's
you know life history is relevant
because it provides us insight into
those larger social the larger social
history and the larger dynamics
and the interplay of the individual
within that you know so a biography of a
biography of a you know famous person I
mean that's that's not you know I mean
there's I'd there's a time and place for
everything but as an anthropologist I'm
interested in the ordinary people and
what their experiences are and in
teachers and what that can teach us and
and about humanity yes yes
now the other books along the way to
light in dark times were those more
about justice and well so I mentioned
that I have a book on women in
homelessness yes and that book is called
love sorrow and rage and then the
subtitle is destitute women in a
Manhattan residents and the other book I
have is some Street addicts in the
political economy it's called and then
I've done edited volumes most recent one
is on gender in the Republic of Georgia
which is the in the former Soviet Union
Caucasus yes culture nation in history
it's a feminist perspectives and culture
nation in history in the South Caucasus
and I have an edited volume on war and I
have an edited volume on writing
anthropology which is one of the things
that I'm very keen on because I think
it's very important for us
anthropologists to we know so much and
we need to communicate what we
understand about the world better to
larger audiences and put be voices in
public conversations which kind of leads
me to light in dark times yeah
so if I can share that with you yes and
I also want to say out of the you know
when you were first starting to teach us
about about John Jay College and
the student body that's there at this
public at this public College City
College that this is a this is this is
also one of the things that leads more
conversations and more of your research
it's let it because you get to see
firsthand diverse women lower SES mid
SES etc socioeconomic status and that
surrounding yourself there it gives you
a better understanding of the the the
violent in justices that that are
occurring in the in humanity well we do
have a very diverse student body as you
as you as I said and a lot of our
students I mean they they struggle with
limited access to resources we do have
students who are homeless are we too
many of them we have students who are
food insecure we most of our students
work and many of them work full-time
I mean nearly all of our students work
and so they don't come from privileged
backgrounds and yet they managed to
accomplish enormous amounts and I'm very
proud of them
so but let me tell you a little bit
about light and dark times
yes um the human search for meaning that
it is so cool that it is like I when I
saw that I got really excited because to
me disseminating the complexity to the
youth is really important right so so
here's that so you what you just showed
your audience is a flyer from a talk
that my collaborator Charlotte Hollins
and I just stood at my school which was
a wonderful experience the first time we
brought our collaborative work to an
audience and it was great so let me tell
you a little bit about it really briefly
so as as you mentioned I'm was president
of the American Anthropological
Association and my term ended last
and the night before your term ends you
give a big address to an audience of
anthropologists so they're aware I don't
know between 800 and 1,000 people in the
audience and I had my address was at
that time and my address was titled four
stories four stories a lament and an
affirmation and what it was was a talk
that was an engagement with Hannah
Arendt and bertolt brecht about the dark
times of the past and bringing them into
the present and I was talking to this
audience of anthropologists about what I
thought we need to be doing at this
particular historical moment in these
dark times as anthropologists and what
some things and that was my four stories
the four things that I've come to say to
this audience so unbeknownst to me there
was an artist in the audience and her
name is Charlotte Hollins mm-hmm and she
was listening to my talk and was so
inspired by the talk that she went back
to her hotel room and spent the entire
night drawing making a visual
representation of my talk which I
received the next day Wow and it is the
most gorgeous
I felt so affirmed because she
understood so much of what I was trying
to convey yes in this gorgeous drawing
good so I'm not going to go through
details but I will tell you that
ultimately I got in touch with her
mm-hmm and I said to her what do you
think about if we work together and
create a graphic book based on my talk
and your illustration and that is what
we've been doing since last January
first by Skype she's in London and then
she came to New York to stay with me and
we have been working together since the
end of June
with a little break in between where she
had to go as she went back home but
she's I'm here in San Jose and she is
back in the Orkut and we've been we
finished about two-thirds of the book
and what we have done there within that
drawing that you see there there are two
little characters one in red and one in
blue mm-hmm and I'm the character in red
and she's the character in blue and we
go on this search and encounter moat
many philosophers and thinkers and
writers and anthropologists and
political scientists and others who are
going to help us understand the dark
times of the past and the dark and the
dark times the present but the light
that there's light there all the way
through which is what the search is is
not for we don't be not optimistic if
you think of the word optimism as okay
everything's gonna work out happily ever
after
but we're searching for meaning like
we're searching for hope in the sense
that the meaning of hope as we're gonna
make sense out of things and that's our
so we're searching for understanding and
knowledge and one of the one of the and
where we're searching for mutual
understanding on a gigantic scale that
is one of what part of the search and
and where we can find that in part is
through this rich store of
anthropological knowledge about people
everywhere and anywhere
produced by anthropologists anywhere and
everywhere and that is that is where we
can lift the cotton-wool of obfuscation
that pulls the wool over our eyes
and and Abbi and and and unders come to
understanding by the illumination that
we get through knowledge and that is our
book mmm that's so cool and it's
gorgeous and it's visually visually and
Greta awesome awesome I love that so
so now just tell us about this the the
importance of piercing the veil and also
seeing and then how that helps see the
light and kind of like a little bit on
that journey like how do you explain so
we're on this journey and we are you
know meeting these different
philosophers there were the four stories
that I mentioned earlier the four things
for us to think about is that we really
we need we all need to be introspective
we need to reflect on ourselves and what
our assumptions are what our beliefs are
what our what our presumptions are and
and really be honest with ourselves
about our motivations and our attitudes
and our beliefs so be introspective
that's really important for all of us
yeah
meditation is great for that yeah yeah
and also we need to think in dark times
that and and actually this is where
Hannah Arendt comes in and I won't go
into those specifics right now but she
she talks about what thinking is and
it's thinking is is not reasoning for
example because you know we can find
reasons for all sorts of things and
justify all sorts of terrible things
that's not thinking so we need to think
and be thoughtful in in these dark times
in any dark times and what would you say
thinking is then it's it's it's akin to
introspection but it's different because
it's it's it's really a silent
intercourse with one's self yes
and but it also requires
and going beyond your own opinion about
something
absolutely it's it's it's no
multi-perspective synthesis that's
that's one way to put it and then the
third the third thing we really need to
do is think about and understand truth
lies and trivia the danger of the
trivial so much of what we well we we
know that we're living in a post truth
world if you will and and that it's very
difficult to curate to know what's true
and what's not true because it's because
we're bombarded with information to
parse for signal in all the noise
exactly and also and and and you know
this is for anthropologists but for
everybody we have to avoid the trivial
and and for for scholars we have to
avoid producing the trivial we have to
produce really important things not just
stuff to to publish or to you know
support unique it needs to be meaningful
if you meet needs to be a contribution
but we also have to avoid the trivial
you know in terms of you know we're so
exposed to junk yeah and you know we
have to avoid that because there's that
stuff is distraction it's distraction
and then we're we're and then then the
darkness is is there there's a you allow
it amount of waking hours we have every
day exactly 16 of them on average per
human so so there's if there's only a
hundred twenty billion hours of
collective human attention on the planet
if you direct as much of that attention
towards knowledge and truth and
multi-perspective synthesis as possible
and away from the noise then you're
going to have more of prosperous this
doesn't mean that you can't relax your
mind and look at something you know well
it can't be all that we do okay it can't
be all that we pay attention to so
there's that and then the fourth thing
is envisioning and all
turn ative world yes what we don't do is
allow ourself the space yes to imagine a
different way of organizing the world we
don't do that and we have to do that we
have to provide the space and if we've
gone through introspection and we are
thinking and you know if we are
understanding what is what are lies and
different kinds of lies because that's
what we go through we talk about radical
deception and what that is these are
concepts that's a concept from you know
I had a rent also button and she also
talked about radical evil by the way and
radical evil is you know a system a
political economic system that turns
human beings into superfluous makes them
superfluous yes makes them redundant
makes them be human to human eyes so all
of these things are in this you know
search human search for meaning all of
this and it's all visually presented and
incredibly and I think done and then we
get to this last piece which is creating
the space and the time to envision an
alternative world and how that might
look and not allow you know not be not
just allow ourselves to be locked into
an ism or an eye some kind of ideology
but really look what is important to us
and that piece in my talk and in the
book is really very moving to me goes
full circle back to my students because
one of this one of my students brought
into class the idea of for us to do this
and so one of the things that we did one
day in class
and this student organized this event
this activity he had each student write
down on a piece of paper the most
important thing that he that we thought
as individuals to change that needed
changing for an alternative world and he
put them in in a jar yeah and then we
each had to pick out one person's thing
but it wasn't our own yeah and read it
aloud and it was the most incredible
because when you mentioned earlier about
caring and community everything that the
students said were all about that it was
all about that and it was not about
making money
and it wasn't about getting material
objects you know accumulating material
goods it wasn't about any of those
things it was all about us becoming
human beings who care about one another
love and love and caring and community
and together we'd be able to find the
justice that we were talking about
earlier yeah because with that we can
then plan a new world yes that is just
yes that is just what a cool activity on
each putting in one thing that we want
to see us change in the world and then
to read each other's outloud that is
very cool and how often do we do we stop
and think well what would it be what
would be the template for an alternative
world exactly and I've been I've called
that I guess now two words civilization
design or planetary architecture these
have been kind of like two phrases that
have been thrown
around a little bit to feel out how
people what people react to them but
those phrases are exactly what slow down
feel what would we want to design
civilization as what would be an ideal
architecture for the flow of resources
to to people for flourishing on the
planet mm-hmm
so and I love how you made it so clear
about about not getting lost in what's
trivial because there are plenty of
people trying to capitalize on you being
lost in what's trivial yes exactly and
that's the thing that we're we all
struggle with this we all struggle with
it so that's that's where that's my
that's my work in a nutshell and and
where I'm at today so so when I get back
to New York from the conference
Charlotte and I are going to continue to
work on light in dark times and we we
have a sense of urgency about this book
project because we feel that you know
you know these are I mean listen we're
here in San Jose breathing in this air
amidst a you know people in power who
tell us there's no issues with with
climate change and you know it's um you
know we we want the world we want the
world to be sustainable it's worth
sustaining and human life is worth
sustaining and we all want to be safe
yeah
wow I feel so blessed
thank you these things for news on the
show this has been this has been such a
pleasure I'm just I I have a lot of love
for what you care about and what you're
writing about what you're teaching so
thank you so much really appreciate you
coming thank you very very much thank
you my pleasure and this is this again
I'm a kid in a knowledge Haven right so
fun being here thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it give
us your thoughts in the comments below
we'd love to hear from you
check out Triple A as well their links
in the bio please give them a
look and keep building the future going
manifesting your dreams into the world
everyone thank you for tuning in
much love and we'll see you soon bye Wow
great I feel so so good that was oh I
feel so enriched and like oh you're so
wonderful thank you